aucune femme ne recourt de gaieté de
coeur à l'avortement
il suffit d'écouter les femmes c'est
toujours un drame
cela restera toujours un drame c'est
pourquoi si le projet qui vous est
présenté tient compte de la situation de
fait existantes
s'il admet la possibilité d'une
interruption de grossesse c'est pour la
contrôler et autant que possible en
dissuader la femme actuellement celles
qui se trouvent dans cette situation
sociale sion de détresse qui s'en
préoccupe la loi les rejette non
seulement dans l'opprobre la honte et la
solitude mais aussi dans l'anonymat et
l'angoissé poursuites
aujourd'hui la france que dis je
l'humanité a perdu une femme qui a
oeuvré toute sa vie pour que d'autres
puissent exercer leur liberté
cette femme un nom elle s'appelle simone
veil
je n'ai jamais connu cette dame et les
causes qu'elle a défendu me touche
énormément notamment le droit qu'à
chaque être humain à disposer de son
corps comme il l'entend
c'est bien là une extension de la loi
pour libérer qui a permis à de
nombreuses femmes du z endroit pourtant
légitime
par extension c'est un combat pour la
liberté pour les libertés c'est d'user
de nos corps comme bon nous semble
alors même si elle nous a quittés le 30
juin 2010 est son combat reste pourtant
inachevée et malheureusement d'actualité
trop d'injustices continue d'exister
trop souvent les femmes n'ont pas les
mêmes droits que les hommes des droits
que l'on croyait acquis continue d'être
attaqué il faut rester vigilant elle a
connu le pire et pourtant elle a offert
le meilleur
merci simone veil d'avoir ouvert la voie
merci à vous d'avoir toujours résisté
merci d'avoir inspiré de nombreuses
générations
ne soyons pas triste mais
réjouissons-nous des combat qu'elle a
mené car sans elle la position de la
femme en france ne serait pas ce qu'elle
est aujourd'hui
simone je ne sais pas si l'eau de
l'existant mais si c'est le cas vous
pouvez reposer en paix
d'autres ont pris le relais merci
d'avoir ouvert la voie mes respects
monsieur greu
[Musique]